welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and did loki just completely
rewrite marvel history with a cartoon
clock
loki's arrest by the tba in episode 1
included an insightful animated sequence
dropping major
reveals about past multiversal wars
godly timekeepers and how merely
punching and late for work makes you a
time
terrorist what is this an amazon
shipping center this cartoon is a
classic
everything's fine assurance that you
just know is foreshadowing inevitable
chaos
later in the story and with terms like
multiversal war
and nexus event and promises from kevin
feige that loki will have the most
impact on the mcu of all of its shows i
think miss minutes just laid out not
only how loki creator michael waldron is
calling the shots for his doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness script
but also feige's bigger plans for the
next avengers 5 crossover event
so as he's being processed in the tva
loki enters a room with empty rows of
stanchions designed clearly to force
variants to watch this animated sequence
from tva mascot
miss minutes who explains long ago
there was a vast multiversal war
countless unique timelines
battled each other for supremacy nearly
resulting in the total destruction of
whale everything she then says the
all-knowing timekeepers brought peace by
condensing this multiverse into the
sacred timeline
and that if too many variants step off
this timeline and create unchecked nexus
events
that could branch off into madness
leading to another multiversal war
now there are a few ways you could
interpret this first is that marvel
could be laying the groundwork for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness especially with the words of
multiverse and madness appearing in the
same sentence there and by bringing back
the term nexus last seen in one division
as a nod to wanda maximoff's being
a nexus being who can transcend
realities marvel's plan with loki is to
unravel this sacred timeline into
tangled branches that the scarlet witch
could get lost in
during her search for a reality with her
children turning her into a god level
chaotic threat that doctor strange will
have to deal with but speaking of doctor
strange
doesn't this tva history contradict what
the ancient one told us about the
multiverse in the past
for one an endgame the ancient one said
the infinity stones
create what you experience as the flow
of time but now according to the tva the
timekeepers do that
now the timekeepers protect and preserve
the proper flow of time for everyone
and everything and the infinity stones
are about as valuable as hot sauce in
the package roar
still useful just you know low trade in
value also miss minute says
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war
implying that the modern era of mcu
history has been all part of
one sacred timeline but doesn't that
contradict the ancient one previously
blasting doctor strange through
several dimensions all while asking him
who are you
in this vast multiverse now it is worth
keeping in mind that this is all
propaganda from the tva it's cooked up
by the tva narrative commission
so you can only trust this history so
much but on the other hand mobius does
say
time works differently in the tva loki
was arrested after the battle of new
york in 2012
four years before the ancient one met
doctor strange and talked about the
multiverse in the present tense like
that
and to the tva the events of end game
set in multiple eras of time
all kind of unfold simultaneously from
their perspective kind of like how they
could just step
into years 1549 or 1858 so the events of
the loki series could still
create or rather recreate the multiverse
as we know it in those other mcu films
this is why i've suggested that time and
the mcu could be a flat circle
which multiverse war long ago is the
same multiverse award
the mcu is about to cycle back into in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
now if that's too confusing it doesn't
float your boat another way of looking
at this past multiverse of war is that
maybe all that floating fuselage
is the aftermath of a war between cosmic
entities like the celestials in my
marvel family tree video i explained how
the celestials came about after a war
with the aspirants
in the first firmament but really that's
more dawn of the universe kind of stuff
rather than
historical timelines battling for
supremacy so there is a third way of
interpreting this as a nod to marvel's
secret wars event like trust me readers
of marvel comics saw those interweaving
realities zapping each other and we were
like
oh secret wars before we continue thanks
to upstart for sponsoring this video
is your monthly credit card balance
keeping you up at night sweating through
your sheets like your air conditioner's
broken well upstart can be that blast of
cool air to help you finally feel the
relief of being credit card debt free
upstart is a fast and easy way to get a
personal loan to pay off your debt all
online over half a million people have
used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment with a five minute
online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
from one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and other information
provided in your loan application
you can get approved the same day and
can receive funds as fast as one
business day
don't let your credit card debt give you
the night sweats those should only come
from being scared the monster lives
under your bed so find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com new
rockstars don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
new rockstars now quickly on why this is
such a big deal there are actually two
secret wars crossover events in the
comics the first was in 1985 when the
beyonder
teleported marvel heroes and villains to
his battle world realm to duke it out
but the more recent secret wars event
was in 2015 and it featured a more
apocalyptic collision between
marvel earth 616 and the ultimate marvel
earth 1610
in a much richer battle world landscape
this time assembled by dr
doom and it begins with these universe
versus universe
incursions which feature electric bolts
filling the atmosphere with similar
imagery of lightning
in little zaps between the timelines in
the tva
animation and later on on that holo
projector film strip
you do see the number 616 so while the
mcu is set in earth 19999
maybe the tva's connections to earth 616
in a past multiversal war and yeah miss
minute's multiverse award could be
referring to a past secret wars event
either with a past stage of heroes or if
time is a flat circle
a future avengers lineup including the
fantastic four
and x-men that we will be looping back
to in a few years
look i love secret wars and adventures
in game directors the russo brothers
teased that an avengers secret wars
movie could be a title they'd return to
direct but i think we have to admit
knowing marvel studios track record i
doubt they would jump into a secret wars
event right away
and instead build up to it but i do
think the first step was taken here with
loki see one of vision left us with the
scarlet witch as a fully powered nexus
being
armed with the darkhold obsessed with
finding a reality with her children
as hints in the post-credits scene and
reveals from the creators that doctor
strange
was far more intertwined with wanda's
descent than it seemed and now loki is
giving us clear definitions of
how nexus beings impact the fabric of
reality
and how dangerous and chaotic the
multiverse is to the existing order of
the mcu
inevitably unraveling the timekeeper's
sacred timeline into
a multiverse of madness featuring dr
strange which could end up being a kind
of sorcerer war
involving doctor strange the scarlet
witch maybe even loki but i hope that it
results in a house of
m inspired convergence perhaps doctor
strange
merges everything back into a new
restored sacred timeline
but now including mutants in the
fantastic four and doctor doom
cue the fantastic four movie and then
after that secret wars
and it all started with a little cartoon
spark wait a minute oh my god that's the
new rockstars logo we're in on it all
the
time
hey you can support this channel by
checking out our great loki inspired
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
they have an amazing loki out of time
shirt follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for breakdowns of
everything loki thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you